-Right now, today is Friday,
and that's usually when
I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my in-box,
I return some e-mails,
and I, of course,
send out thank-you notes.
And I was running a bit behind.
Can I write out some
thank-you notes right now?
Is that okay with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you! I appreciate that.
James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing music,
please?
[ Soft music playing ]
Eh, how about
something different?
[ Up-beat music playing ]
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
♪ I wanna say thank you ♪
♪ I wanna say thank you, now ♪
♪ Thank you ♪
♪ I wanna say thank you,
now, now ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank You, nutcrackers,
for always looking like
you just saw what Kanye posted.
-Ay-yi-yi!
What?!
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, restaurants whose
specials today are
cranberry Turkey,
for making it pretty obvious
this food is a week old.
It's like,
"That's cranberry turkey?"
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, mistletoe,
for being the most festive way
to get cancelled.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Spotify Wrapped,
or, as you're also known,
"Spotify: Taylor's Version."
She crushed it.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, the morning
after black Friday,
for being the moment
I wake up next to
a new flat-screen TV like,
"Wait, did we..."
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, real Christmas trees,
for being so excited
to come home, relax,
and take off your Spanx.
Just relax.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you,
Christmas craft fairs,
for being a fun, festive way
to walk around
dozens of little shops
and going, "Eh."
"Do we need this?"
-No, I'm good.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, poinsettias,
for being the
po-tay-to/po-tah-to
of Christmas.
Is it "poinsettas,
poinsettas, poinsettas"?
Poinsettias?
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you,
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer,
for teaching children
that it doesn't matter
if you're different.
What matters is that
you're useful once a year.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our "Thank You Notes."